oceans Sun fishes are well known for
rapidly gaining a lot of weight on a
diet based on jellyfish the relationship
between the elapsed time T in days since
an ocean fish since an ocean sunfish is
born and its mass M of T in milligrams
is modeled by the following function all
right complete the following sentence
about the daily percent change in the
mass of the sunfish every day there is a
blank percent addition or removal from
the mass of the sunfish so one thing
that we can we know from almost from the
get-go we know that the that the sunfish
gains weight and we also see that as T
grows as T grows the exponent here is
going to grow and if you grow an
exponent on something that is larger
than one M of T is going to grow so I
already know it's going to be about
addition to the mass of the sunfish but
let's think about how much is added
every day so let's think about it well
let's see if we can rewrite this this is
I'm going to just focus on the right
hand side of this expression so 1.35 to
the T over six plus five that's the same
thing as 1.3 five to the fifth power
times one point three five to the T over
sixth power and that's going to be equal
to one point three five to the fifth
power times one point three five and I
can separate this T over six as one six
times T so one point three five to the
one sixth power and then that being
raised to the teeth to the teeth power
so let's think about it every day as T
increases by one now we can say that
we're going to take the previous days
the previous days mass and multiply it
by this common ratio the common ratio
here isn't the way I've written it isn't
one point three five it's one point
three five to the one sixth power let me
draw a little table here to make that
really really clear and all of that
algebraic manipulation I just did is
just so I could simplify this so I have
some common
ratio to the teeth power so T and M of T
so based on how I've just written it
when T is zero well as T is 0 this is 1
so then we just have our initial our
initial aim at our initial mass is going
to be one point three five to the fifth
power and then when T is equal to 1 when
T is equal to 1 it's going to be our
initial mass one point three five to the
fifth power times our common ratio times
one point three five to the one sixth
power when T equals two we're just going
to multiply what we had at T equals one
we're just going to multiply that times
one point three five to the one sixth
again and so every day well let me get
every day we are growing every day we're
growing by our common ratio one point
three five to the one sixth power
actually let me get a calculator out
we're allowed to use calculators in this
exercise so one point three five to the
to the open parenthesis 1 divided by six
closed parenthesis power is equal to 1.0
1.0 five I'll say one point oh five 1
approximately so this is approximately
one point oh five one so we could say
this is approximately one point three
five times 1.05 one to the teeth power
so every day we are growing by a factor
of one point oh five one well growing by
a factor of one point oh five one means
that you're adding a little bit more
than five percent you're adding zero
point five one every day of your mass so
that's you're adding five point one
percent and if you're rounding to the
nearest percent we would say there is a
5 percent addition to the mass of the
sunfish every day